[Aplausos]
[Música]
irlanda es el país con la mayor densidad
de músicos famosos per cápita de todo el
mundo tal cual como lo oís hablamos de
un país con menos de 5 millones de
habitantes para que os hagáis una idea
la capital del perú lima tiene casi el
doble de población pues bien en este
país tan despoblado es donde han nacido
estrellas de la talla de sydney o connor
cranberries en ya the chieftains y por
supuesto
bono el deudos estrella del rock a lo
mejor de las más influyentes y de las
más acogerán listo pero hay otra cosa
por la que irlanda también es famosa
seguro que muchos de los que estéis
viendo este vídeo sobre todo desde
españa estaréis pensando en emigrar a
este país y razones no os faltan
hablamos del segundo país más rico de la
eurozona los irlandeses tienen más
dinero que sus vecinos del reino unido o
de suiza y todo esto debería
sorprendernos si tenemos en cuenta que
hace sólo 30 años
irlanda era un país tan pobre como lo
puede ser grecia
[Música]
tal cual como lo oís por aquel entonces
uno de cada cinco estudiantes irlandeses
emigraba a otros países como eeuu o
australia es más a día de hoy en estos
lugares hay más población con sangre
irlandesa que en la propia irlanda y sin
embargo hoy en día es una de las metas
tecnológicas del mundo muchos pensaréis
que la razón que explica este
crecimiento tan espectacular se debe
únicamente a los impuestos bajos es
cierto que irlanda ofrece condiciones
fiscales muy favorables para que se
establezcan las grandes multinacionales
[Música]
pero pensadlo bien porque otros países
como las islas seychelles o la república
de liberia también ofrecen condiciones
fiscales muy favorables y no son ni la
mitad de ricos que irlanda así que la
pregunta es qué ha hecho este país para
lograr semejante crecimiento económico
cómo es posible que incluso tras la
crisis financiera
irlanda siga siendo un país a la altura
de suiza hoy vamos a responder a esas
preguntas pero antes vamos a ver un poco
de historia
[Música]
más pobres de los ricos irlanda nació en
el año 1922 tal cual como lo oís hasta
entonces toda la isla pertenecía a la
corona británica y las relaciones con la
metrópoli no eran especialmente buenas
para los ingleses
irlanda era una tierra de católicos
paletos que obviaban el trabajo y que se
dedicaban a tener hijos como si no
existiera el mañana y por eso tras
declarar su independencia una de las
primeras cosas que hace irlanda es
cortar todas sus relaciones con londres
y ya de paso con el resto del mundo
para que os hagáis una idea irlanda es
el único país angloparlante que se
declaró neutral durante la segunda
guerra mundial pero no sólo eso durante
años los sucesivos gobiernos irlandeses
cerraron el país a calicanto y lo
protegieron del comercio internacional e
incluso llegaron a prohibir que los
extranjeros pudieran comprar o invertir
en empresas locales y cuál fue el
resultado de estas políticas pues una
crisis económica bestial por suerte como
los irlandeses hablan inglés en lugar de
morirse de hambre hacían las maletas y
se marchaban a eeuu y ojo que no
hablamos de unos pocos aventureros en
apenas unas pocas décadas la población
de irlanda se redujo a la mitad
y por supuesto la industria nacional
nunca llegó a tener ese boom que se
esperaban pensadlo bien en un país tan
pequeño es imposible encontrar las
herramientas y las materias primas
necesarias para poder construir máquinas
y fábricas así que se tienen que
importar pero si el gobierno se dedica a
poner aranceles y barreras a las cosas
que compras en el exterior lo vas a
tener bastante complicado
si quieres montar tu propia empresa y
por eso en 1957 bajo el gobierno de sean
tomas o kelly irlanda da un giro de 180
grados a su política comercial así es
cómo pasan de no comprarle nada al resto
del mundo a abrir de par en par las
puertas del país al mercado
internacional
[Música]
años después firmaría un acuerdo de
libre comercio con reino unido y una
década más tarde entrarían en la
comunidad europea que es lo que ahora
conocemos como la unión europea pero
esperad un momento mis queridos amigos
liberales que sé que muchos estáis
viendo este vídeo contener vuestro
entusiasmo por un momento porque esta
apertura al libre mercado no salió tan
bien como se esperaban los pobres
irlandeses
[Música]
pensadlo bien durante décadas irlanda se
había cerrado el comercio y había
nacionalizado buena parte de sus
empresas cuando una empresa sabe que no
tiene que competir por conseguir
clientes deja de invertir dinero en
innovar eso explica por ejemplo que en
pleno 1980 los habitantes de la ciudad
de cork en el sur de la isla estuviesen
tan acostumbrados a los apagones
eléctricos
lógicamente tenían una red de cableado
que no se había reparado ni donovan
desde hacía décadas así ocurría
prácticamente con cualquier otro sector
económico cuando de repente la economía
irlandesa permite comprar bienes en el
extranjero aparecen nuevos productos
mucho mejores de mucha mejor calidad y
más competitivos y qué ocurre con las
empresas locales os preguntaréis pues
que desaparecen y con ellas miles de
personas pierden su trabajo
para que os hagáis una idea en 1987
irlanda tenía un 17% de desempleo así
que nuevamente los jóvenes irlandeses
tenían que hacer sus maletas y buscar un
puesto de trabajo en el extranjero los
que seguís visual polític desde hace
tiempo ya sabéis que la inmigración no
es un problema para un país sabéis qué
es lo que sí nos tiene que preocupar lo
contrario la emigración en el caso de
irlanda quien se marchaba del país pues
justo aquellos que estaban mejor
preparados mejor cualificados y que
tenían normalmente títulos
universitarios o de educación superior a
este fenómeno se le conoce como fuga de
cerebros
[Música]
pero esperad un momento porque todavía
hay más para atraer a esas
multinacionales estadounidenses el
gobierno de irlanda había bajado los
impuestos y por supuesto que esta
estrategia les funcionó a empresas como
microsoft intel o apple eligieron
irlanda como su sede fiscal para todo el
mercado europeo el problema que sólo
montaban una oficina comercial con un
contable es decir que su contribución a
la riqueza del país era francamente
pobre por si esto fuera poco el mismo
gobierno que le ponía una alfombra roja
a las empresas subía los impuestos a los
ciudadanos que llegaban a pagar hasta un
60 por ciento de su renta como os podéis
imaginar con algo tenían que financiar
un estado que quería parecerse a
dinamarca pero sin tener el dinero
[Música]
y por si esto fuera poco la legislación
irlandesa tampoco ponía las cosas muy
fáciles para los locales que querían
montar empresas y contratar a gente así
que fijaros en la stampa destrucción de
empleo destrucción de empresas locales
un gasto público imposible de pagar y
cientos de miles de irlandeses
marchándose del país estamos ya en 1988
y en estos momentos the economist saca
este artículo hablando de la tierra que
vio nacer abono
los más pobres de los ricos la purina
landa se había portado como si fuera
rica y ahora deben pagar el precio vale
bien ya hemos visto todo lo malo y ahora
la pregunta es cómo consiguieron salir
de este bache ahora mismo os lo cuento
[Música]
el rugido del 'tigre celta' año 1987
charles acne gana las elecciones al
gobierno irlandés y se encuentra con un
país sumido en la más absoluta miseria y
se da cuenta de algo muy importante no
puedes abrir un país a la economía
internacional sin antes mejorar su
sistema productivo doméstico
por supuesto que empresas como oracle o
hp estaban encantadas de establecerse en
irlanda para pagar menos impuestos que
en eeuu pero realmente estaban
dispuestas a montar una fábrica o un
centro de investigación que diera
trabajo a miles de personas la respuesta
es no
[Música]
porque os preguntaréis lo primero es que
tenían que lidiar con la legislación
laboral irlandesa que era todo un
viacrucis legal pero no sólo eso
recordáis que os decía que los impuestos
sobre la renta llegaban hasta el 60 por
ciento eso significa que por muy altos
que fueran los sueldos lo que le llegaba
al trabajador a su bolsillo era una
ínfima parte de lo que le pagaban en
otras palabras que esos irlandeses que
tenían buena formación buena
cualificación y que podían trabajar en
las empresas de alta tecnología
preferían marcharse a eeuu donde pagaban
menos impuestos y por tanto ganaban más
dinero
[Música]
por cierto que esto tan bonito que está
sonando es the forgotten voice un grupo
de rock de irlanda que nos ha mandado su
música si os gusta encontrareis más
información sobre ellos en los enlaces
de la descripción
[Música]
así que la primera medida de jazmín
consistió en llegar a un acuerdo con la
patronal y los sindicatos para que los
sueldos crecieran al ritmo que crecía la
economía del país por el otro lado bajó
los impuestos sobre la renta que tenían
que pagar los ciudadanos de tal forma
que los trabajadores terminaban ganando
más dinero con el mismo salario y sabéis
que en pocos años
estas medidas empezaron a dar resultados
la planta de gm para karen y slip para
2.000 trabajos para el año 2000 en poco
tiempo todas estas empresas que habían
montado su sede fiscal en territorio
irlandés empezaron a abrir también
fábricas y centros de investigación en
los que tenían que contratar a montones
de trabajadores así que el desempleo se
recortaba los sueldos subían y además el
estado recaudaba más dinero pero no sólo
eso toda esta reducción de trabas
burocráticas unidas al pacto social
consiguió que surgieran muchísimas
empresas irlandesas
quién de vosotros no ha volado alguna
vez en ryanair quien de vosotros no se
ha comprado alguna vez una camiseta en
el primar quien no se ha bebido alguna
vez una cerveza guinness pues todas
estas empresas fueron creadas o se
expandieron internacionalmente en estos
años y eso explica que en los años 90 la
economía irlandesa creciera casi al
mismo ritmo que la de china de repente
era normal que llegaras a una peluquería
de dublín y te ofrecieran una copita de
champán o que mucha gente se fuera a
pasar el fin de semana a nueva york para
hacer compras eran los años del llamado
tigre celta
[Música]
a los sueldos irlandeses no llegaban a
dos terceras partes de los británicos el
año pasado y en algunos sectores los
superaron pero esperad un momento porque
no todo es tan bonito en estos años de
optimismo exacerbado los bancos se
dedicaron a dar hipotecas a todo hijo de
vecino sin siquiera mirar si eran
solventes y por supuesto también daban
préstamos para financiar toda clase de
derroches de lo más rocambolesco para
que os hagáis una idea en esta época
llegó a surgir una empresa que alquilaba
helicópteros para que los niños y las
niñas hicieran su primera comunión por
los aires para que os hagáis una idea en
estos años llegó a surgir una empresa
que alquilaba helicópteros para que los
niños y las niñas hicieran su primera
comunión desde los aires
y todo esto llevó a una crisis
financiera de la que hablaremos en otro
vídeo si no os lo queréis perder
suscribiros al canal para estar al tanto
de todas nuestras actualizaciones
mientras tanto después de conocer algo
más de la política irlandesa
debéis echar un vistazo a la de escocia
en este vídeo os explico porque escocia
volverá a intentar independizarse del
rey me hace clic aquí para verlo
y ahora la pregunta es creéis que el
modelo irlandés podría servir para otros
países como españa o grecia os parece
que otros países de latinoamérica
podrían beneficiarse de atraer y
mantener a empresas multinacionales
extranjeras podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto
[Música]